so first of all the thing that people
first experience when they look at
python
there is a it is very readable
but there's also like a spatial
structure to it
can you explain the indentation style of
python and what is the magic to it space
are important for readability of any
kind of text
if you take a cookbook recipe
and you remove all the sort of
all the bullets and other markup
and you just crunch all the text
together maybe you leave the spaces
between the words but that's all you
leave
when you're in the kitchen trying to
figure out oh what are the ingredients
and what are the steps
and where does this step end and the
next step begin you're going to have a
hard time if it's if it's just one solid
block of text
on the other hand what what a typical
cookbook does if the paper is not too
expensive
each recipe starts on its own page maybe
there's a picture next to it the list of
ingredients comes first
uh there's a standard notation there's
there's shortcuts so that you don't have
to sort of write two sentences on how
you have to cut the onion because there
are only three ways that people ever cut
onions in a kitchen small medium and in
slices or something like that
right none of my examples make any sense
to real Cooks of course but yeah
we're talking to programmers with a
metaphor of cooking I love it but there
is a strictness to the spacing that
python defines so there's some
a looser thing some stricter things but
the four spaces for the
for the indentation is really
interesting it it really um it really
defines what the language looks and
feels like because indentation sort of
taking a block of text and then having
inside that block of text
a smaller block of text that is indented
further
as sort of a group it's it's it's like
you have a a bulleted list
in a complex business document and
inside some of the bullets are other
bulleted lists you will indent those too
if each bulleted list is indented
several inches then at two levels deep
there's no no space left on the page to
put any of the words of the text so you
can't indent too far on the other hand
if you don't indent at all you can tell
whether something is a top level bullet
or a second level bullet or a third
level bullet so you have to have
some compromise and uh based on Ancient
conventions
and the sort of the typical width of a
computer screen in the 80s
and all sorts of things sort of
we we came up with sort of four spaces
as a compromise
I mean there there are groups there are
large groups of people who code with uh
two spaces per indent level for example
the Google style guide
uh all the Google python code and I
think also all the Google C plus plus
code is indented with only two spaces
per block if you're not used to that
it's harder to at a glance
understand the code because the the sort
of the the high level structure is
determined by the indentation on the
other hand there are there are other
programming languages where the
indentation is uh eight spaces or a
whole tab stop in in sort of classic
Unix and to me that looks weird because
you you sort of after three indent
levels you've you've got no room left
well there's some languages where the
indentation is a recommendation
it's a stylistic one the code compiles
even without any indentation
and then python really indentations a
fundamental part of the language right
it doesn't have to be four spaces so you
you can code python with two spaces per
block or or six Paces or 12 if you
really want to go wild but
sort of everything
that belongs to the same block needs to
be indented the same way
in practice in most other languages
people recommend doing that anyway if
you look at
C or rust or C plus plus
all those languages Java don't have a
requirement of indentation
but except in extreme cases
they're just as anal about having their
code properly indented so any IDE that
the syntax highlighting that works with
Java or C plus plus they will yell at
you aggressively if you don't do proper
indentation they'd suggests the proper
indentation for you like uh in C you
type a few words and then you type a
curly brace which there is their notion
of sort of begin and an indented block
uh then you hit return and then it
automatically indents four or eight
spaces depending on your style
preferences or how your editor is
configured was there a possible Universe
in which you considered having braces in
Python absolutely yeah well there's a 60
40 70 30 in your head uh uh what was the
trade-off for a long time I was actually
convinced that the indentation was just
better
uh without context I would still claim
that indentation is better
uh it reduces clutter however
as I started to say earlier context is
almost everything
and in the context of coding
most programmers are familiar with
multiple languages even if they're only
good at one or two
and apart from Python and maybe Fortran
I don't know how that's written these
days anymore but all the other languages
Java rust CC plus plus JavaScript type
script Pearl
are all using curly braces uh to sort of
indicate blocks and so python is the odd
one out
just a radical idea do you still as a
radical Renegade revolutionary do you
still stand behind this idea of space of
uh indentation versus braces
like what what can you dig into it a
little bit more
why you still stand behind indentation
because context is not the whole story
history in in a sense provides more
context so for python
there's no chance that we can switch
python is using curly braces for
something else dictionaries mostly
we would get in trouble if we wanted to
switch just like you couldn't redefine C
to use indentation
even if you agree that it that
indentation sort of
in a Greenfield environment would be
better
you can't change that kind of thing in a
language yeah it's hard enough to reach
agreement over over much more Minor
Details maybe I mean in the past in
Python we did have a big debate about
tabs versus spaces and four spaces
versus fewer or more
and we sort of came up with
a recommended standard and sort of
options for people who want to be
different
but yes I guess the thought experiment
I'd like you to consider is if you could
travel back through time when the when
the compatibility is not an issue and he
started python all over again
can you make the case for uh indentation
still
well it frees up a pair of
matched brackets of which there are
never enough in the world
uh for other purposes it really makes
the language slightly
sort of
easier to grasp for people who don't
already know
another programming language
because the sort of one of the things
and I I mostly got this from my mentors
who were
taught me programming language design in
the earlier 80s when you're teaching
programming
for for the the total newbie who has not
coded before in not in any other
language
uh a whole bunch of Concepts in
programming are very alien or
sort of
new and and maybe very interesting but
also distracting and confusing and there
are many different things you have to
learn you have to sort of
in a typical
13-week programming course you have to
if it's like really
learning to program from scratch you
have to cover algorithms you have to
cover data structures you have to cover
syntax you have to cover variables Loops
functions recursion classes
Expressions operators there are so many
Concepts if you you sort of
if you can spend a little less time
having to worry about the syntax
the the classic example was often
oh the compiler complains every time I
put a semicolon in the wrong place or I
forget to put a semicolon
uh python doesn't have semicolons in
that sense so you can't forget them and
you're also not
sort of misled into putting them where
they don't belong because you don't
learn about them in the first place
the flip side of that is forcing the
strictness onto the beginning programmer
to teach them that programming is uh
values attention to details you don't
get to just write the way you write in
English they have other details that
they have to pay attention to so I think
they'll they'll still get the message
about uh
paying attention to detail